I had totally goddamn it Kevin Smith I
know I didn't want to eat him Oh Kevin
Smith blew my ship up with his sadness
coming profusely in there a minute
you're all so mean
just running into the side of it duck
duck Oh goose I don't know what to get
in help yourself is this yeah I can tell
hit everybody
are you proud of me yet ma and everyone
else watching work should icing to this
jet pack wasn't actually gonna shoot oh
wow and I'm right back to her started oh
no no you don't go in that vent don't
how doe not deadly though
everybody wants to oh oh oh now let's go
I clicked on it before didn't know okay
bye um I needed that hose sir where do I
need to go oh hello no no no you can't
do this debate [ __ ]
okay that's why all right good god
there's so many
rukia I'm gonna spook you good
hello mr. spider I shall use my power to
smite them slice them oh my goodness
can't you see I'm standing here ha ha ha
hey we're do it back but ma is only one
lorry I'll a little share cranberry
oh it's beautiful
is that the magic kingdom of Sonic land
behind you or something equally is
disturbing as Disney oh hey
pick it up speed now Wow it's like they
actually ripped the sonic engine out of
the old ah bill it's sick nods and oh my
god it's just I wish nothing but success
on the creators of these cool games I
just watch wrath I just geeked out about
it so much and I'm sorry if I do but I
love cheese geez well I don't know you
put it as an option game how was I not
supposed to try it beautiful hall that's
adorable Tim oh man when he made the
decision to go on an adventure glug glug
glug glug
a minute they'd like might be a bad idea
okay
damn and man what's with you you're
stuffed in it by this very witness Oh as
you can see by this doctors analysis the
defendant had taken quite oh God thanks
for watching all of the videos in this
compilation are available in the
description so check them out
and if you'd like to see more in the
future please leave a like to let me
know if you enjoyed this video and you'd
like to see more on a daily basis please
subscribe today or if you're already
subscribed share this video with a
friend thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye